with bruce jenner these are yeah these
these are actually uh king and the sting
uh
fan submission videos of some of their
costumes
real fast rip my dress looks like my
friend garcia's girlfriend
that's a great one man
oh there's bobby lee
that's a lot more bobby lee right there
yeah way more
oh king of the sting oh that's dope
oh
[Music]
oh there you go in hernandez right
this is uh hulk hogan with his uh sex
tape
he's got a six case he does hulk hogan
yeah
it's like security footage from his home
somebody stole him i had an entire bid
on it
i know he has sex tape yeah oh there's a
little guy
oh there's the there's the terrorist
that's gonna scare people
dope costume bro that's hilarious look
at that isis costume
that's fantastic
oh undertaker oh that guy was on our
podcast last week that's frank john
the mortician right yeah yeah yeah it's
frowned upon
what did he what did he say huh oh
everything really
learned all about it you can get married
twelve feet if you want
instead of six mm-hmm should we see a
nice little montage of them yeah
yeah let me see that dude all right i
got to take this now that's going to
look because i cannot see
there you go it's chappelle
that's when i came in to have the mouse
i went oh you're dave chappelle oh
because he always rocks the onesie it's
a good costume
a little bit of blood put it on the
plants or anything like that you ever
know anybody did anything like that
no now can you eat near the bodies or
not it's frowned upon
i bet he's a you know by the bodies
though
do a lot of people die holding their
penis i feel like no
how fast can you get me in the ground if
i die you got to do any like eight hour
packages or anything
get you in the ground pretty quick
depending upon the cemetery amen
and how deep can you get me can i go 12
feet or it's only six you can go deeper
have they ever caught anybody in your
industry doing something vile or yes
stealing blood or copping femurs or
something out of deceased or anything
and if you ever accidentally had the had
the wrong body in a cat in a closed
casket
no and now is it hard for you personally
if you have trouble is it tough to meet
women or something like that if you
working in the death trade you know
i would not say that it's a chick magnet
that was good what were you drinking
there said liquid death
yeah that's a lot of water yeah oh
really yeah it's a fancy water company i
thought you're back drinking again
i'm gonna say i found a drinking partner
yeah if i come out man i'll come over
here
yeah no not if you come out of the
closet well i'm still waiting for that
day
bro if i come out of the closet who
would i spend time with out of this room
i'll put that up on the candy board
[Laughter]
it would probably still be cat thanks
theo
ooh that one's dope oh that's good
that's sam tripoli on the right
[Laughter]
i was gonna be the rat king too hence
why the back room is so messed i can't
find the costume
oh i have it at home oh man i told you
he likes to keep it close to him
he could bust out anytime sometimes if
there's trouble outside in the yard i'll
put it on
oh yeah scare the kids oh bro scare
everybody
oh yeah he nailed it
oh he did great that was great oh
there's cat
oh cat tina there baby yeah huh
there's brendan well that's so is that
simple
mankind
cyrus and her dad oh that's no that's
beth
and uh rip wheeler from yellowstone is
it
yeah that's a deep pool if you're a
yellowstone fan you know exactly i think
that's miley cyrus there no
i'm telling you that's yellowstone doug
that's miley cyrus and matt west i think
or mata
matt west matt west from uh pbr
nope oh whatev and megan his his lovely
fiancee megan and megan is living with v
on the side
uh that that does it for our king and
this is great
fancy
[Music]
it's missions king of nice games